who here's a fan of murder you know now
some of you probably met you like
murdering right now what I meant is you
just you interested in in murders I'm a
bit of a murder murder Oh file is that
there I don't know I wouldn't I wouldn't
go around boasting about it now I just
enjoy reading about murder right
occasionally committing a murder well
you probably remember a very famous
murder in 1989 the Menendez brothers
okay you all remember this famously
murdered their parents right here in Los
Angeles
well someone recently discovered an old
NBA trading card that showed the
Menendez brothers sitting in the
background courtside this is true this
is real check it out there's Mark
Jackson his card and then you go into
the background and right they're sitting
ringside are the Menendez brothers yes
the photo was taken a few days after the
Menendez brothers murdered their parents
they went to that basketball game and
then they show up on the NBA trading car
yeah which is insane now I mentioned
this before I thought that's crazy and
then I looked into it it turns out this
is not the only time murderers have been
spotted photobombing professional sports
trading cards
it's weird but it's kind of a trend Wow
it really is yeah here's New York Mets
picture Noah syndergaard and in the
background drug lord el chapo is here's
a check this one out here's Green Bay
Packer Antonio Freeman doing the Lambeau
leap right behind him Jeffrey Dahmer
what's and he's clearly not enjoying the
game here's the most decorated Olympian
of all time swimmer Michael Phelps see
him right there in the background
accused murderer Robert Durst is under
yeah here's James the champion Springer
Spaniel who won Best in Show at
Westminster in 2007 in the background
convicted dog fighter Michael Vick
and finally we showed this one last time
but it's so strange I have to show it
again here's hall-of-fame running back
Oh J Simpson that's his card right there
in the background don't ask me how it's
possible convicted criminal
[Applause]